With more and more international collaborations and multinational staff members working on anime coming about
We may get to the point where this debate as what counts as anime and what doesn't becomes moot.
"That is the most melancholy pasta"
[Excuse me, what?]
"I brought you a big Toblerone"
"NOOT NOOT"
"WHAT'S HAPPENING?!"
"We have to go back, Kate"
"I did this! I MADE THE CHOICE!"
"We have to go back!"
Uhh, is anime broken right now?
Can we- is- is this gonna get patched out?
Ah yes, the temperature's coming down, the leaves are starting to turn red, and you still didn't find your summer love, which can mean only one thing:
The new season of anime is just about to start. Where you can forget all your sorrows with some cute anime girls. Or guys, we don't judge here.
In our community, we are all believers of equality...
...In degeneracy
Now, as your friendly neighborhood "anime" "watcher", it's my jobs to go through all the "anime" this new season so you don't have to.
And who knows? Maybe we'll both find a gem we can get excited about, follow religiously, then watch as it slowly disappoints us and drops all the hype you held at the beginning.
Let's start off with everyone's favourite...
"Cooking show"
Now, I know what you're thinking.
"What spicy new dishes are they're gonna give us this season"
'cause, you know, that's the best part of the show. Seeing how they're able to handle their "fresh meat" into new, interesting dishes and nothing. Else.
Speaking of sequels I'll definitely be watching, "Kekkai Sensen" has picked up exactly where it left off and holy shit!
If I had a boner before, this scene has definitely finished it off. Thank you again
I'm glad to see that it's still full of character and as stylish as ever. So yeah, not much to add if you've already seen the first season except god, I miss the old ending.
Not that the new ones are bad but can we just agree that this was one of the best ED's in recent memory?
You know normally I wouldn't give a show like this a second look, but thanks to "Made in Abyss"
I'm now obligated to check out every show about chibi explorers, on the off chance that they'll turn out amazing.
It was atmospheric, it was cute, and the world seems interesting so you know what I might actually give this one a-
Wait, hold on a second, did- did they just...?
So as I was saying, the show is awful and giving it a chance was a massive mistake.
"Hey"
"Wanna hear the most annoying sound in the world?"
*Asta screaming*
So "Black Clover" was hyped up as being one of the possible new big shonen's of this generation and
HA HA HA ha ha ha ha ha...
So far, it's been an absolute mess. Not even counting the main character's fucking constant
*Asta SCREAM*
It's as generic a shonen can be right now, and it feels like the show is 10 years old and has much more in common with titles in the era of The Big 3
rather than how the genre has slowly evolved in recent times.
at the moment, it's just a very poor man's "Naruto," or an equally wealthy man's "Fairy Tale"
A moment of silence, please, for the comment section.
*in the distance* "Did he just imply "Fairy Tale" was bad!?"
In the same way that "My Hero Academia" shows us how we can take every generic shonen trope and refine it to a T,
"Black Clover" has shown us how we can take every generic shonen trope and make it completely generic.
The main character is annoying as hell, we were given the fucking flashback in episode 2, nothing about this show is special so far, and you know the part that pisses me off the most?
I'm still probably gonna watch anyway 'cause I'm shonen trash.
So "Inuyashiki" marks the second manga on my recommended manga video to be adapted by Mapper.
But I was honestly a bit disappointed in this first episode.
The pacing was lightning fast and we weren't given enough time to actually care about these characters or let the consequences of any actions sink in.
It feels like this should have been two episodes worth of material, but it is just the first episode after all
and every seasonal anime has to start off with a bang so I still have high hopes for this
If anything, I can thank you for letting Man with a Mission complete their Holy Trinity of Hype-as-Balls one-liner anime openings.
♪ Raise your flag - Man with a Mission ♪
♪ database - Man with a Mission ♪
♪ My Hero - Man with a Mission ♪
I feel like after "Eromanga Sensei", I've been given kind of a bad rep when it comes to little sisters in anime.
For some reason, I really can't tell.
As a lot of you have been telling me to watch this new Imouto anime
but, I mean, after "Eromanga Sensei," I really don't know what new things can be done.
"You always ignore me now! You never listen to what I have to say, what's going o-!?"
*Gigguk sighs*
Wait a minute, this is just the first two minutes of the episode!
OH! I... I see, it's- it's- it's the good old incest bait-and-switch! the oldest- The oldest trick in the book...
It's about a light novel author obsessed with writing light novels about little sisters.
So I assume this is the memoirs of the "Eromanga Sensei" author because I can definitely see where the inspiration comes from.
It's been 14 years since the last "Kino's Journey" so I'm guessing a bunch of you new anime fans
So I'm guessing a bunch of you newer anime fans will have never heard of it so I'm just gonna pull out my old fag card and say watch this first episode.
It's an episodic show, so you don't need to watch the original, all you need to know is that it's about a girl travelling to different countries
each with different rules and laws that explore interesting philosophies and mentalities
The first episode looks at what could possibly happen if there was a country where the act of murder was legal. The original anime was great, and this one's looking like you'll be good too.
Wait a minute. This is Negima.
Why is this Negima? Is this new Negima? Oh I've not heard of this before!?
♪ Happy Material - Touta Konoe ♪
Back in the day, when I was just but a teenager, I was enamored by the works of Ken Akamatsu, the harem God at the time
and his works like "Love Hina" and "Negima!" still hold a close place in my heart as they helped shape me to the man I am today.
*Guy sneezes*
*... and that happens*
I regret nothing
The "Negima!" manga though, ended up turning into an awesome shonen battle series
So excuse me while I squeal in nostalgia because they used the original OP
And there's Negi! And there's all the girls! And Ava's gone full kiss-shot and-
WHAT!?
[WHAT?!]
WHAT!?!?
WHAT THE FUCK JUST HAPPENED?!
[I DON'T KNOW!]
"Everybody clap your hands."
*Jaden clapping*
[Still going...]
*Jaden begins clapping again."
So we have a tournament where twelve Super-powered combatants fight to the death and the winner gets their wish granted.
Isn't this just "Fate?" Isn't this just "Fate" with edge?
Isn't this just "Fate" with a lot of fucking edge??
I mean it looks fun as hell and the fight choreography is great, but let's be real here: This is just "Edge/stay night"
And hell, that isn't even clearly the edgiest show of the season because we've got a group of super-powered Nazis led by a charismatic leader trying to bring down the world's destruction.
That's right! It's "Akame Ga Hitler!"
The brakes don't stop on this edge train though because next we've got "Evil or Live."
That's right, in this cruel world where you're given two choices:
You can either live.
or... you evil *chuckles*
*chuckling* what the fuck does that even mean?
*Anime girl grunting with exhaustion*
*and somehow trips on a pebble and face-plants.*
And finally, if there just wasn't enough edge this season, we have "King's Game." where you have a show with all the ingredients to bake that perfect edge cake!
See, what you want to do is start off with your standard death game base, sprinkle in some exploding bodies,
mix in some suicide with just a dash of rape. Now, put it in the oven and let it sit for about season and voila!
You've just baked yourself a nice new- shit... Oi! Who gave me the "Mirai Nikki" ingredients list?!
So there's an anime called "Just Because" why?
I- just- just- just fucking because, okay?
But~ after the first episode, I have no idea what the show is actually about so let's just read the synopsis.
"At the end of the second semester of 3rd year of high school, four students are prepared for graduation and feel the ending to their high-school life.
But that changes a little with the arrival of a transfer student."
Okay, I still have no idea what the show is actually about.
All right guv'na! We in London now! 5 million pounds?
Is this how much the pounds gone down after Brexit!?
Wait a minute, I've lived in London, this ain't fucking West London.
Unless... is this the legendary Zone 6 I've heard so much about?
Wait, are those... Yeah, they are! What are they doing in London?! Bloody immigrants!
Alright, so this is looking like the newest hot show of the season and I can wholly see why.
It has the same vibe and appeal of something like Harry Potter, with a world of mystique, mages and magic that you want to explore and learn more of without being in any way a ripoff.
So far, there hasn't really been a hook in the plot or with anything going on, but the atmosphere and setting have certainly intrigued me as I just want to see more of this world.
So yeah, with all the things considered, the season is looking up!
We got some great sequels, some good originals, and a mix of fun ones; so yeah, that's Fall 2017.
There's nothing else literally that's left to talk about!
At all!
Please don't make me do it...
What is this?
Is this visual cancer?
Or just outright terrorism?
I don't think this counts as a terror attack because ISIS haven't claimed responsibility for this...
Maybe this is just Japan's declaration of war...
against humanity...
If this can get a second season, then this is it.
This is the final proof we need to confirm that we are on the darkest timeline
There is only one path that awaits us now...
Wait a minute, this is airing on Anime Strike.
CRISIS AVERTED!
If you want to avoid the dark Imouto dystopia at all costs, then you can do so by putting them where they belong.
In the fucking trash.
That's why you can get your exclusive Sagiri trash and Umaru dumpster pins from Otaku Pin Club, links are in the description below, more details coming up.
Hey guys. Hope you enjoyed the video
I'd like to give a shout out to Otaku Pin Club in this video, as you can guess from their name they make anime pins.
So yeah, they approached me and asked if I had any ideas for any designs so of course I came up with the trash Sagiri and dumpster Umaru pins.
If you want either of those one-of-a-kind pins, then pre-orders are in the description below, it'll come out sometime next month
as you can see they do a high-quality metal pin, so yeah
I'm really looking forward to seeing how those pins turn out and also I'd like to thank Jarred Catel, Vincent Mooney, Laioken, Gigguk,
Who I'm now just gonna rename Patreon Gigguk to avoid confusion
and everyone else at patreon for also helping to support me and making this video possible
Anyway, not any more updates from me. I will be in Japan again next week, so woooo!
Full Weeb Mode! So yeah, that's it from me. I've been Gigguk and I will see you all next time.